the banks have lobbyists in Washington  in numbers I've never seen their coming  not just once a month these guys are  coming in two and three and four times a  day they're making phone calls they've  got their position papers and they just  keep slamming in the same direction over  and over and over and people who just  want to advocate for American families  people who want some changes who want to  level the playing field they just don't  have that kind of lobbying power and so  what we're really watching here is a  David and Goliath story of it's just a  monumental you know before the crash I  had most of my savings in Lehman  Brothers ah I don't have a question I  just want you to hold me  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]